hello everyone i'm alana and i am very
excited about
dying light 2. in this video we are
going to be watching a dying light 2
update for march 2021
uh from the dev team talking about where
the game is at uh
obviously been a long time coming at
this point dying light was awesome
i loved it for a whole bunch of reasons
but before we actually get into watching
the update which is about two minutes
and 46 seconds long
i did want to speak to um a little bit
of why i'm so excited about dying light
too
specifically i am someone who is very
interested in video games from a
technical perspective
um interested in games that i feel like
are taking
steps to further the medium that are
doing things that i find to be
technically
very difficult um that are unique in
that approach
um while there are plenty of games i'm
excited about in
any other sense the stuff that i really
really get into when it comes to just
marketing which is effectively what this
kind of video is is more specifically
in relation to the boundaries that they
are pushing now i've seen dying light to
a number of times i have interviewed
devs i hosted
their e3 panel not last year but the
year before because we didn't have e3
last year so there are a bunch of things
that i have spoken to the dev team about
and um the thing that really excites me
about this game
is kind of an evolution of uh something
ken levine spoke about
at a gdc which is the game developers
conference
a number of years ago dying light 2 is
one of the first
aaa games that seems to very much be
building into this
concept which to explain it in a very
simple way um i would totally recommend
it if you can go watch ken levine's
original talk if you don't know ken
levine he is the creator of bioshock
he is working on a game right now but if
you don't have the time to do that
uh it is essentially uh
about approaching games as though
players have individual pieces of lego
and while the lego will eventually all
create the same thing the same castle
there are different colors to get there
um and and to again simplify even that
concept
it's basically about letting players
have
more control over the worlds that they
inhabit
about their choices having a visual
impact on the world that they inhabit
for example um there is tech that is
being developed
right now that is specifically uh
catered to basically creating an ai
version of a voice actor
which would allow voice lines to be
delivered in different orders so
every single player would have a very
unique experience and a unique
experience in theory every time they
play the game i have seen games that
have played with the the tech of
having voices in different orders and
while it sounds really absurd it
actually does work
fairly well from what i've seen i don't
know that anything has shipped with it
yet unless there's something that i'm
missing but
the idea is basically that based on the
things that you have done prior
uh a system will be funneled in your
direction that will
pick this piece of dialogue and this
piece of dialogue and this piece of
dialogue and put them in a paragraph
so nothing is scripted there are no more
set pieces there isn't
the song bird moment from bioshock
infinite anymore because that stuff
can't
really belong in a game that is more
driven by ai
and it's not necessarily procedurally
generated while while
it is that it's not what the public
thinks of when they think of
procedurally generated video games
it is ultimately just more player
impact on the story and not in a way
that exists like a telltale game where
one outcome is bad um but only minorly
it is it is an evolution of of that kind
of thing
dying light too does it in a way that
the world itself
should actually evolve based on uh which
faction
players want to spend the most time with
so say you spend time with
you know one faction versus another you
will start to change things to look like
that faction
uh would or how they would outfit their
bases or whatever else
so this is a beginning of this thing
that i think is going to have a very
significant impact on video games going
forward
the narrative side of it is a lot more
complicated and a lot tougher to get
right and would be more focused on
you know if you spend this much time
talking to this npc
they will have more power over time and
then maybe uh
they will be promoted to a certain role
and then the world will start to look
like
kind of you might have some of their
propaganda for example
but that is the simplest way that i feel
like i can explain this concept i'm sure
i've just done that poorly
but it is something that i find
extremely exciting um
that i think should really change the
way video games are played uh ken levine
himself
said uh bioshock is just half-life
re-skinned
and a lot of first-person shooters are
really just a different different
iteration of doom
a lot of video games still tell their
stories the way that films tell stories
in a very you know scripted cutscene
heavy way and while i love that and i
don't want that to go anywhere
there are very cinematic games that i'm
a huge fan of
i think uh the medium has so much more
room
to create unique experiences uh which
naturally it is doing all the time but
also in the
aaa space with this kind of ai
approach to building a world to
empowering
specific npcs and to
changing the player character's
relationships
with those npcs based on the choices
they actually make rather than it just
being oh the ending
uh had different colored explosions it
should be the world's transformed to
look like this because you made these
choices along the way so
that is five minutes of me explaining
that that hopefully
makes sense um but it's why i'm very
very very very excited about dying light
too outside of just really enjoying the
first game a whole lot
um i think it's really fun still holds
up today as well if you haven't played
it and they also released a pretty fun
multiplayer mode too so
check it out regardless but um now i'm
gonna hit play this is the dying light
to update march 2021 and i'm watching it
on
uh gamespot's channel which is why you
see that little logo down here all right
let's do it
okay don't get me wrong
i love dying glide but it's time for
dying light too stop poking us
around what what is he saying
when would it be on sale i want to play
it
right away
it's probably gonna have the same fate
as dead island too
and never come out unfortunately
hello the english studio i hope
everything is doing okay
but i'm really worried about the game i
hope it's not cancelled or something
this is a really cute way to do this do
that [ __ ] dying light too
[ __ ] stop do the dlcs network
this bullet release dying light 2
or give a [ __ ] demo god
[Laughter]
we got a message we understand you are
curious about the game
because you want dying light too to be
good
as you have imagined and maybe you are
even a little
impatient because you have waited a long
time for
any news and updates this is a huge and
complex project
and we needed time cheers it will live
up to our vision
all of us here are putting our hearts
into delivering a game
that you will keep playing for months
we'll be ready to start talking about
dying light 2
very very soon the whole team needs your
trust and support
as this is what motivates us especially
now
when the circumstances are hard for
everyone we are proud of having such
devoted fans as you yeah i like this
presentation a lot express your feelings
and just for you here's a small snippet
of what's coming
please stay with us just a bit longer
and stay safe
thank you i'm gonna make myself smaller
wait stop stop stop i need to make
myself smaller give me a second here we
go
okay
is that it damn it
starting right now you can go to our
discord and find a special there is
nowhere near enough let me just look
back through this game please see if
there's anything in here that like
stands out
so they're right what they're making is
complex and exciting
um and it does seem like they have had
some development troubles from what i
can tell
but i really would have hoped we'd see
more than this
okay so i don't know that there is any
of what i'm speaking about in here um
it's a thing i've been speaking about
for a long time for the record is like i
had originally heard that they were
trying to do it with half-life
alex um and that that didn't quite end
up happening
one thing that i think may they may have
spoken about before is the fact that
everything looks so green and the water
is based on one of the factions having
control of the water if i remember
correctly
um and i mean there are slightly simpler
games that have done that
um wasteland 2 kind of you know
depending on
which of the various places you go to
there will be limited or a lot of water
but i don't feel like that has a
tremendous impact on environments and i
think
i feel like this stuff might have been
like some of the but even like things
like uh
like this flag um really simple but
stuff like that should in theory evolve
based on which factions you have worked
for which you have given money to which
vendors you're buying from even
it's the idea that like if you're
spending money on
one npc's store that there should be
some in-game
uh sort of
visual impact on the fact that that npc
is earning so much money
um the their uh i feel like assassin's
creed
like sort of originally did that with
you know how you can upgrade things but
it's
it should be much more organic than that
it wouldn't be you paying to upgrade a
store
it would be a funneling of money to a
certain organization changing the way
that things look
in the game in a way that no other
player should really have an identical
experience with but i feel like this is
such a small amount of
gameplay
i mean it looks good i'm excited about
whatever this is
damn it i really just so badly wanted to
see more than that it kills me
but regardless even if it kills me
they are right um i'm so curious but i
will wait as long as they need
to release a finished product that
hopefully does still include this idea
that i'm still very very very interested
in
to some extent i don't think it's gonna
like blow my mind with it but it seems
like a beginning of of
something that has a lot of potential to
change the way that stories are told in
video games
um yeah i get the passionate tweets i
think it's something that makes the
video game
community or video game industry in
general just really cool is the amount
of passion that people have for video
games
um that's that's a plus of our media
they they
let you be attached because you feel
like you have agency and that's really
cool
no other medium really does that to the
same extent but at the same time
i never want to rush a dev take as long
as you need to make the cool thing that
i'm going to play please
make it good starting right now you can
go to our discord and find a special dl2
question channel with a form
that will let you send questions
directly to us today i appreciate that
we'll answer all of them in the form of
a series of short ask me anything movies
that's good that's good to know so we're
gonna get some amas from them
i appreciate that but it looks like
that's it i did expect that whole video
to be full of gameplay
um if the dev update is just keep
waiting
i still respect it that's
fair but i guess that's all i have to
say uh thank you for watching i will see
you guys next time
bye